good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 3008 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures the retail part containing
SCP 3008 has been purchased by the
foundation and converted into sites all
public roads leading to or passing by
site have been redirected the entrance
to SCP 3008 is to be monitored at all
times and no one is to enter SCP 3008
outside of testing as permitted by the
senior researcher humans exiting SCP
3008 are to be detained and then
debriefed prior to the administration of
amnestics dependent upon the situation
of their stay in SCP 3008 a cover story
may need to be generated prior to their
release
any other entities exiting a CP 3008 are
to be terminated description SCP 3008 is
a large retail unit previously owned by
and branded as ikea a popular furniture
retail chain a person entering a CP 3008
through the main entrance and then
passing out of sight of the doors will
find themselves translocated into SCP
3081 this displacement will typically go
unnoticed as no change will occur from
the perspective of the victim they will
generally not become aware until they
try to return to the entrance SCP 3081
is a space resembling the inside of an
IKEA furniture store extending far
beyond the limits of what could
physically be contained within the
dimensions of the retail unit current
measurements indicate an area of at
least 10 kilometers squared with no
visible external terminators detected in
any direction inconclusive results from
the use of laser rangefinders has led to
the speculation that the space may be
infinite SCP 3081 is inhabited by an
no number of civilians trapped within
prior to containment gathered data
suggests that they have formed a
rudimentary civilization with NSC p3000
81 including the construction of
settlements and fortifications
for the purpose of defending against SCP
3082
SCP 3008 - are humanoid entities that
exist within SCP 3081 while
superficially resembling humans they
possess exaggerated and inconsistent
bodily proportions often described as
being too short or too tall they possess
no facial features and in all observed
cases where a yellow shirt and blue
trousers consistent with the IKEA
employee uniform SCP 3081
has a rudimentary day/night cycle
determined by the overhead lighting
within the space activating and
deactivating at times consistent with
the opening and closing times of the
original retail store during the night
instances of scp-3467 once inside using
any other door besides the main entrance
to enter the structure or breaking
through the walls of the retail unit
leads into the non-anomalous interior of
the original store since containment
began 14 individuals have managed to
exit SCP 3008 following extensive
debriefing all individuals have met at
menace
mystics and released incident 3008 one
at zero 37 hours on two thousand a human
male exited SCP 3008 followed 10 seconds
later by an instance of scp-3467
[Music]
for more details the man was carrying an
Ikea branded journal seeming to document
his time in SCP 3081 transcribed below
verbatim so i'm writing mr. document
what I can only assume is my sudden
descent into insanity I can't possibly
be that bad a navigator and yet as I
write this I've been trapped in Ikea for
two days I haven't seen another person
in the entire time I've been here I
thought it was a prank at first turn the
place into a maze get all the people out
and see how long it takes me to get lost
then everyone has a good old laugh I
realized that wasn't the case when I
tried to backtrack everything had
changed so I ended up lost instead the
exit it was just row after row of
bookcases so I'm trapped in an Ikea
sounds like the setup for a bad joke the
lights went out at 10 p.m.
nearly giving me a heart attack that
loud electrical thunk sound and then
pitch blackness place is full of beds
though and my phone has a torch on it
but no damn signal so I found a bed and
went to sleep
spent most of the day trying to find my
way out with no luck did find a
restaurant serving those meatballs
though so at least I won't starve that's
probably the punch
to that joke anyway they were still warm
and fresh but I haven't seen anyone
around who could have cooked them made
my way back to the beds before the
lights come out again since it's to dr.
search with him off it's 9:10 a.m. now
the lights came back on a little while
ago I'm sure I've searched the entire
area where I came in now and the exit
obviously isn't here so I'm gonna pick
it direction and hope for the best day
three of my magical IKEA mystery
adventure if I wasn't sure that there
was something seriously weird about this
place before I am now walk for three
hours in a more or less straight line in
certain IKEA joke here before I came
across the ladder next to one of those
huge stock shelves they have here
climbed up to get my bearings and looks
like this place just stretches on
forever like that scene from The Lion
King except instead of trees and grass
it was all shelves and tables and crap I
did see a person moving not too far away
though so I headed over thought it was a
staff member at first it was wearing a
uniform well maybe it was maybe freakish
seven-foot-tall monsters with long arms
short legs and no faces are just the
kinds of thing that they want working at
a super IKEA damn thing completely
ignored me though and with no eyes or
ears I can't even be sure it knew I was
there thought about shoving it or
something to get its attention
but it's hands were big enough to crush
a watermelon so I decided against it it
just kept moving and I eventually lost
sight of it so I decided to carry on the
way I was going anyway
no comfy bed for me tonight looks like
I've entered the improbably hard and
pointy table section of the store guess
I'll have to make do with some bunched
up tablecloths phone battery died during
the day - didn't work anyway but I feel
like I've just lost some vital lifeline
you ever seen one of those cartoons
where they're going through doors in a
hallway and they just pop out of another
door in the same hallway that's how I
feel right now I've seen nothing but the
same identical bookshelf for two days
now just row after row after row of them
I mean come on I love books just as much
as the next guy but this is excessive
I'm obviously still moving forwards
though I can see the signs hanging
overhead passing by too bad none of them
say exit not sure who I was addressing
that question to let's just say it was
practice for the autobiography I'm gonna
write when I get out of here I'll call
it my perfectly normal trip to a regular
old IKEA if I ever get out here finally
found some other people yeah turns out
I'm not the only poor bastard trapped in
here lucky for me I guess my sixth night
here two of those staff things came at
me in the dark different from the first
one I saw but still messed up heard them
coming they were saying that the store
was closed and I had to leave the
building all nice and polite like I'm
not sure which part of that was weirder
that they didn't have mouths or that
they were apparently trying to kill me
while they were saying it came at me
like rabid dogs
so I'll egged it sprinting through IKEA
in the dark like a [ __ ] madman I saw
it when I cleared another stand in front
of those giant stock shelves all lit up
with torches and floodlights they've
built the whole town here got a massive
wall built out of shelves and beds and
tables and whatever else I swear to god
it was the most beautiful thing I'd ever
seen
anyway I guess they saw me coming or
they heard my manly bellows of fear
because they had a gate open and two
people were there waving me in heard the
staff thing slam into the gate behind me
after it closed still politely informing
us that the store was now closed
they wondered off eventually though
they call the town exchange because
that's what's on the sign hanging from
the ceiling directly above it exchange
in returns all led up against the night
using lights they found and plugged into
the power lines and there are beds and
food and people over 50 wonderful people
with regular-sized limbs and a full set
of facial features it's now my seventh
night here and the first one not spent
in darkness a full week living in Ikea
it's probably a TV show and that's
somewhere
now that I'm around other people I'm
starting to feel more normal hmm maybe
normal isn't the word but after a week
with only the sound of my own footsteps
for company I was becoming increasingly
sure that I just got nuts that I was
tied up in some padded room somewhere
banging my head against the wall but no
I feel quite sane now thank you very
much
apparently there are other towns out
there some with more people some with
less I found that fairly mind-boggling
how can that many people go missing with
no one noticing surely someone would
have noticed that everyone who goes to
Ikea seems to vanish or maybe it's not
everyone
maybe we're just the lucky ones the
people here just call those staff
monster sings the staff apparently
they're fine during the day minding
their own business walking the aisles as
soon as the lights go out they go for
bonkers so during the day people go out
to find food water and whatever else
they need apparently there are
restaurants and shops around that get
randomly restocked no one knows how
maybe the staff do it apparently they
aren't very good at their jobs though
because the restocking sometimes takes a
while which means the food needs to be
rationed maybe if they weren't so busy
chasing people around in the dark they
get more done anyway when night comes
the staff go nuts and everyone holds up
inside the walls apparently it's the
same everywhere in this place wherever
this place is the your IKEA from once
all other IKEA is sprang or maybe we're
all still just in the regular IKEA and
this is all some fever dream brought on
by a mind-numbing boredom who knows
been here for ten days now most of the
people I asked said they stopped keeping
track a long time ago and one guy Chris
said he'd been here for years years
apparently there are rumors of people
who do manage to get out the people who
see the exit only to have it vanish
before their very eyes
I get the feeling not everyone believes
that than I do
explains how he got stuck in here in the
first place sort of and I mean come on
staff monsters row after row of
high-quality Swedish furniture I don't
know why they would find a disappearing
door so hard to believe it anyway I went
down scavenging for food in a nearby
shop with Sandra and Jerry today once
you learn the landmarks of this place
it's not so hard to navigate the
overhead signs help a lot but there are
others not too far in the distance a
huge section of those giant stock
shelves is collapsed against each other
and way off in the East we all assume
it's rubies anyway apparently IKEA
doesn't sell compasses it's some kind of
tower that looks like it's made of wood
reaches all the way up to the ceiling
maybe they were trying to break out
through the roof and lights up at night
so there must be people there but
apparently it's a few days walk which
means it must be miles away so no one
here really knows for sure apparently I
got incredibly lucky sleeping on the
open for a week without getting ripped
to bits by the staff that's me lucky
lucky lucky we found some food in the
shop yes the staff restock the during
the night which was nice of them there
was a telephone on the wall so I figured
I'd try it out there was a voice on the
other end but they were just talking
nonsense
random words strung together with no
real meaning you ever see a video of
someone with aphasia kind of sounded
like that didn't answer me when I spoke
to them anyway Sandra says all the
phones in here are the same
asking the journal questions again I was
thinking last night the ceiling on this
place is pretty high and as far as
anyone can tell it goes on forever
shouldn't there be some kind of weather
in here I'm sure I read about some NASA
building that was so big it had its own
weather patterns with clouds and stuff
this place is definitely bigger than
that but now that I think about it I'm
pretty sure I've never felt so much as a
temperature change in here I'll add it
to the grand list weird [ __ ] the
staff attacked the exchange last night
must have been twenty or thirty of them
all just asking us to leave the store
calm as you like while trying to smash
the walls down with their bare hands
apparently this happens pretty regularly
so everyone is prepared for it knives
from the restaurants lawn mower blades
made into hatchets a fire axe one guy
will seem even made a functional
crossbow anyway the walls have holes in
them which I hadn't noticed before
specifically so we can stop out at the
staff when they attack took a couple of
them down myself they don't seem to
bleed which is weird but they go down as
easy as a regular person when she starts
ticking holes in them
we had the hall the bodies away in the
morning apparently the dead ones will
attract more during the night so we had
to get them away from exchange we have a
couple of those trolley things they used
to move big boxes around so we loaded
them up and took them over to pick up
apparently people just named everything
in here after whatever sign is hanging
overhead pickup was a grizzly there were
hundreds maybe thousands of dead staff
all piled up there was no smell which
was a blessing
apparently in addition to not bleeding
these things don't rot either my
curiosity got the better of me while we
were unloading though so I took a look
at one of the more cut-up ones they're
just the skin or something that looks
like skin all the way through no muscle
no bone no organs
are they even really alive in the first
place certainly seem like they have
bones when they're moving around
pounding on the walls I'm sure I felt
more resistance than just skin when the
knife went in during the night maybe
something happens to them when they die
just one more thing on the ever
increasing list of weird [ __ ] that goes
on in here I guess something occurred to
me after the staff attacked the other
night every time you see a situation
like this on TV or in a film like it's
the end of the world or everyone is
trapped on an island or whatever
once groups like ours start to form but
people always seem to turn on each other
fighting for food or dominance or
whatever else that hasn't happened here
apparently people from other towns come
by from time to time just to check in or
occasionally trade if they're short on
something but everything is always
cordial friendly even maybe it's the
threat of the staff or perhaps the
constant restocking of supplies in the
shops means there's nothing much to
fight over maybe people are just better
than they're generally given credit for
that's a nice thought I think I'll go
with that one a dozen people showed up
at the gates this afternoon from a town
called trolleys apparently the staff
broke through the walls and tore the
town apart during the night these 12 are
the only survivors out of over a hundred
we let them in obviously one more point
in the human decency call later I asked
if anyone knew how many of these towns
were out there between us and the new
folks we managed to come up with over 20
names 20 towns filled with people and
who knows how many beyond that the motto
for this place should be how is that
even possible
surely someone somewhere must be looking
for the thousands of people that must be
in here
I've been here for a little over two
months now not that much changes as it
turns out a couple of new people showed
up same stories the rest of us nice
little trip to Ikea and suddenly they're
trapped in Billy bookcases house of
faceless weirdos the staff attacked the
exchange once or twice a week we kill
them and all off their bodies sometimes
they hurt some of us first they killed
the guy called Jared a couple of weeks
back
it was awful correctly turns out regular
humans still bleed in here even if the
staff belt we tried our best but none of
us are doctors Jared was a good guy Ezra
better we all do it occurred to me that
a couple of days after that none of us
were really looking for a way out of
here I don't even know where we'd start
one of those quadcopter things with a
camera attached buzz passed exchanged
today I thought it meant that someone
was finally looking for us that help was
on the way apparently it's not the first
time this happened though same thing
happened a few months ago and everyone
is still here no idea if it's sauce it
didn't stop if it did just kept flying
until we could no longer see it note
based on recovery time of the journal
this entry appears to line up
approximately with our first successful
test piloting a drone in sinus EP 3081
analysis of footage shows a waltz
settlement under a sign labeled exchange
in returns attempts to relocate the
settlement fail origin of previously
cited drones is unknown
I started talking to people about the
stuff they miss from home during dinner
today probably not the best idea I've
ever had everyone seemed pretty down
after a bunch of people here have
families husbands and wives
it's dogs Franklin apparently has a pet
llama though I'm not sure I buy that but
apparently some of the people here have
some seriously odd gaps in their
knowledge three of them had never heard
of the International Space Station two
of them seemed to think was the prime
minister and one of them had apparently
never heard of the Statue of Liberty I
believed them too they seemed just as
confused as the rest of us the more I
thought about it though the more it
started to explain a few things what if
the reason no one is looking for all us
missing people is because we haven't all
come from the same place this is gonna
sound weird maybe that should be the
motto for this place but what if all the
people here have come here from
different dimensions realities whatever
you call it
I've seen enough TV shows to know the
drill Sara comes from a place where
there's no statue of liberty they didn't
launch a space station where was CMAs
from if everyone here came from
different places even from ones that
seem identical there'd be no huge
missing persons panic no mass search
we'd just be a blip a single missing
person in a world of non-stop news well
that was a fun train of thought
just realize that yesterday was the
six-month anniversary of my arrival here
I wonder if IKEA sells party hats the
routine around here has remained more or
less the same more new folks show up on
every couple of weeks or so
food supplies go up and down but we've
never actually had a major shortage
occasionally we get a visitor from one
of the nearby towns usually checkouts or
I'll 6:30 we check in with each other
from time to time
occasionally trade supplies if someone
gets particularly low on something it's
comforting in a way a reminder that we
aren't alone here some small glimmer of
civilization sometimes they bring
medical supplies
apparently there's a pharmacy a few
towns down from checkouts that gets
restocked every now and then so they
share out what they can I've never heard
of an Ikea with a pharmacy before but at
this point I wouldn't be surprised if
someone stumbled on an ikea organ
harvesting lab would certainly explain
the staff speaking of our faceless
jailers their attacks have been getting
worse lately three or four times a week
now with twice as many staff as there
used to be no idea where they all come
from or why the attacks have increased
we tried following one of them during
the day a few weeks ago me and Sara
wanted to see if they led back to a
staff room or something didn't seem to
go anywhere though just randomly walked
through the aisles we had to turn back
before we found anything
we've been reinforcing the walls trying
to arm ourselves better certainly no
lack of materials to use while seam has
been making more crossbows but it's
pretty slow going
too bad IKEA doesn't sell guns
never thought I'd say that nope no new
personnel have entered SCP 3008 at site
in the timespan indicated in this entry
the attacks are getting bad now almost
every night now with so many staff that
the body's almost piled high enough for
others to climb the walls I think we're
in real trouble here exchanges I think
exchange is done we got hit pretty bad
last night not many casualties but the
wall is wrecked we finally figured out
why the attacks have been escalating to
a box of supplies had a chunk of one of
the staff in there no idea how it
happened but apparently a piece of one
will draw them as well as a full body
too late now in any case there's too
many bodies first the haul-away and
still have time to fix the wall before
midnight candice is called the meeting i
suspect there will be talk of abandoning
exchange maybe try and get shelter the
check outs or something it's already
getting late though I don't think we'll
have time to make maybe some of us will
I was fine for that first week out in
the dark after all but then how often
can I keep getting lucky I'm only
writing this for a sense of closure I
guess for me or for anyone who finds
this if this is the final entry here I
hope whoever is reading this is doing so
from outside of this place my biggest
fear
if I do die tonight I'll just wake up
here again in the morning note this is
the last entry it is assumed that while
he was attempting to reach the checkouts
settlement he was separated from the
rest of his group by pursuing a CP 3008
two instance and happened upon the
accident booth
I have been to Ikea a few times and that
guy's recollection not that different
from mine
just saying that place is a war zone
also why do I keep on getting assigned
interdimensional scps I don't know
anyway I think that about does it for
today thank you very much for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
go away I'm just kidding goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to curva gaming Zach Geller
James Saba Katherine Jews Jackson Marek
Pablo ice 917 Arlington the cat Karim
Allah schmoovy
Justin de Pury kuma Riley Shawn Murphy
Traver W peg white crew Nicholas James
boo Jack Bryson Billy my archive curator
neck tie verbal Alex Gill Dre rook the
Android Jacob Ganim pity quartz 5 6 3
and tree hero if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well
there's at patreon.com forward slash the
Vulcan thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]